like a scene from the cold war when an
iron curtain cut through europe this is
no man's land in eastern ukraine
a border between territory held by the
government on one side and russia backed
separatists on the other
and it's not just land that's been
divided
this is the only place families can
cross from luhansk and donetsk after
separatists blocked other routes
foreign
victims of a diplomatic failure to
resolve a conflict between ukraine and
russia despite eight years of trying
so the occupied part of ukraine is about
800 metres that way this is the path
that people wanting to cross between the
two sides have to go we're not actually
allowed beyond this point here but
because of the rules that they're under
on the other side they're only actually
allowed to come here over to this side
once a month
with tensions escalating france's
president pictured in moscow last week
had hoped to breathe life into what's
known as the minsk accords
they aim to secure a lasting peace but
kiev wants them to deliver a fully
sovereign ukraine while moscow seeks to
use them to gain permanent influence
sometimes i think there's been a
cultural predisposition
in western capitals to assume that if we
have a geopolitical problem on our
doorstep in europe
then somehow
with good faith
common sense
reason and pragmatic concessions on both
sides you can broker a solution which
not only
resolves that problem but also leaves
everybody more or less happy
i suggest that in this case that is not
possible
residents also conflicted
with
this woman wants ukraine reunited so her
daughter can see her father in kiev more
if warnings of a new invasion are right
though their journey is about to become
even harder
debra haynes sky news stanista luhanska
eastern ukraine